Saudi Arabia hacked the head of Amazon
mb/s hacked bezels so yeah apparently
that happened it's like freakin Tony
Stark
apparently Saudi Arabia's cuddly Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman sent Jeff
Bezos a whatsapp message that contained
a nasty piece of code which secretly
harvested the Amazon founders data
quicker than well Amazon the message
contained a picture of the Saudi and
swedish flags Sweden Saudi Arabia called
the allegations absurd and silly and in
a way I mean Bezos is at the forefront
of cutting-edge technology
Saudi Arabia is at the forefront of
cutting up its detractors one sees a
progressive future of robots and space
travel beyond the seas a progressive
future of women being allowed to drive
if they ask nicely
if Bezos can be fooled by whatsapp spam
what chance do the rest of us have also
they swap numbers at a dinner party in
Hollywood and MPs reportedly sent a
picture of a hot woman with a sexist
joke to besos salt billionaires are made
to be different from the rest of us here
are some of the other one percenters the
NBS has apparently been swapping digits
with oh and lindsay lohan so what can we
learn be careful what you click and
don't send pictures of you if you like
what you see then hit the subscribe
button oh you can watch one of these
amazing videos